Okay, so we have some questions to go through today.
First of all, I hope everybody had a good Fourth of July.
It had a great celebration, it's awesome fireworks, and moving through the, always the
Fourth of July for me, it's always like, oh my goodness, it's actually summer.
And how did it all slip by so quickly and we seem to be on the downhill of summer.
So get out and join the sunshine, I hope, it's very healing for everybody to get some sun
and one day it can be very healing.
So let's jump into some questions, first of all, we'll open it up for questions here.
One question that came through is a person that said they were prescribed an estrogen blocking
medication to prevent their breast cancer from recurring.
Patients with breast cancer or variant cancer, prostate cancer that are hormonally driven cancers.
Typically the breast cancer has to be estrogen positive to do this or HER, two positive to do this.
But they'll use an estrogen blocker with prostate cancer patients on almost all of them.
They'll recommend testosterone blocker.
There's pros and cons to those medications.
With breast cancer and a variant cancer and uterine cancer that are estrogen driven,
the estrogen blockers do a work to block estrogens, they work very well.
And what most, what I hear feedback from most women is that they work too well.
It can, you know, with you zap all your estrogen out of your body, it makes you feel like a different person.
So it has some negatives to a person.
If the person is still in a position where they want to have more babies down the road,
well, that becomes a major problem.
It could put you into, you know, a different time of life and a quick hurry.
And you may never come out of that.
So there's positivism negatives to that.
The thought process is that because your cancer is estrogen driven,
then if we get rid of the estrogen, it's going to stop the cancer.
Well, there's some truth to that.
But that's not ultimately the cause of the cancer as the estrogen.
And you're not just getting rid of the bad estrogen, you're getting rid of all the estrogen.
So you got to weigh out the pros and cons to that.
So I'm not saying you shouldn't do that.
And legally say you shouldn't do that.
It may be the best thing for you.
But the reason why we give dim and the other products, the set of gastro,
the other products that we use for estrogen driven cancers is that there's natural ways
to help decrease the bad estrogens without getting rid of the good estrogens.
And that's what those products do.
So I can understand your oncologist wanting to do that.
But you got to weigh out the pros and cons of that.
I can't tell you to not or to to to take a drug or not to take a drug.
So I can just give you that information and I recommend that you research that as well.
And we have a number of I've put together a number of articles and some videos on that as well.
So I recommend that you you look at that in research that as well.
Anything that supplements that may cause kidney stones, obviously a completely different question here.
The answer is yes.
So there are some things in people's supplements that can actually be the cause,
the major cause of kidney stones.
And this is this is where number of months ago, maybe it was longer than that ago.
I did a video on checking your supplements for quality.
And part of that video was on minerals.
That's what we have to talk about when we talk about kidney stones.
How your minerals and your supplements are keylated.
So minerals as they come out of the soil into a plant.
Plants bind minerals with a double bond, typically double bond ameto acid.
And then we eat the plant.
And that's how we're supposed to get our minerals.
And though getting minerals from plant sources,
you're never going to have issues with kidney stones.
Getting minerals made through a company called Albion, or a company called Tracks,
which neither one of those companies sell minerals directly,
but then they sell to good quality supplement companies.
So all the minerals supplements that we use are either food based minerals,
or their minerals from Albion or Tracks,
which are double bond to a glycine, which is an ameto acid,
which is the same way that you find it in a plant source.
So you're not going to have any issues with our supplements with kidney stones,
but you can have issues with over-the-counter mineral supplements.
Typically, it's the carbonates.
So minerals that say calcium carbonate, or magnesium carbonate,
they are very difficult to break down by your body.
If you absorb them, you tend to not break them down,
get it into cells and tissues,
and you excrete them through the kidneys,
and they are a major cause of kidney stones.
So yes, supplements can lead to kidney stones.
Do not take calcium carbonate.
Calcium carbonate is limestone.
Many inexpensive supplement companies will simply wash and clean limestone,
capsulate up its calcium carbonate,
and sell it as a calcium supplement.
Do not take those things.
They can be leading causes of kidney stones.
Other issues with kidney stones are some things in your genetic pathways,
in a nutrient called oxalates,
that normally should be broken down in the gut.
It excreted through your feces,
but people with specific genetic pathway defects
on multiple different genes that are in what we call the oxalate pathways
can lead to kidney stone issues too.
So if you have a lot of oxalate gene defects,
you're going to be much more prone to kidney stones,
and those people really have to watch the calcium consumption,
especially calcium carbonate,
but those people would even want to be even more careful
about other calcium supplements.
Now, we don't recommend high-dose calcium supplements for anybody,
even with somebody with bone loss,
because it's the research is showing that it's really not the calcium
that you need, you know, used to be taught that,
oh, you have some osteoporosis, you need to increase calcium
to 1500 milligrams of calcium a day,
the outcome of that faulty recommendation
has been an increase in heart disease,
and hardening of the arteries, atherosclerosis.
So that's not the decision that should be made.
It is not a calcium deficiency.
Besides the fact that you should be in your calcium
through your vegetables, it is an inflammatory process
to go out of the bone.
So if a person has bone loss,
you do want to increase the green T-extract
that helps decrease that IL-6 inflammation at the bone point.
So the thing that causes kidney stones are oxalates,
the defects of your oxalate pathways,
and poor source calcium.
So those are the things that you do want to look at.
We don't use any of those sources of calcium in our office,
it would be something that you'd be taking over the color.
Next question, can low-afferated levels
cause your hair to fall out?
Not that I know of, I don't think that low-ferited
would cause your hair to fall out.
Typically, when a person has hair loss,
you want to look at thyroid levels,
not so much ferritid levels,
and ferritid and thyroid don't really go together.
Though a person with low thyroid can also have anemia,
it's not the low ferritid levels that are causing the hair loss.
It's the low thyroid level.
So if you're going to get your thyroid checked,
the thing that you want to get checked on your thyroid
is your, I was just typing it here so you know,
is your T3, your T4,
and then you're going to get your total T3, total T4,
your free T3 and free T4, their TSH,
your thyroid antibodies, your TPO antibodies,
and your reverse T3.
Those are the things that you want to do in a full thyroid panel.
So total T3, T4, free T3, T4, TSH, TPO and reverse T3.
If you really want to get a full thyroid panel,
lots of times you'll go in and say,
can I get my thyroid checked?
And they'll simply do a TSH with thyroid stimulated hormone,
which is almost worthless to say,
if you have low thyroid issues,
but if you have hair falling out,
and you're not currently doing something that's damaging,
your hair follicles like chemotherapy,
then you want to look and get your thyroid checked.
So those are the tests that you want to do.
Next question, supplement for somebody who has anemia.
So if a person has anemia, no ferritid levels,
low red blood cell coat,
and there's some different other factors with anemia,
there's multiple different types of anemia.
So understand that.
You could have B12 anemia.
You could have anemia due to multiple different factors.
When we talk about anemia of chronic disease,
which we see commonly with cancer patients,
because of the cancer is possibly sucking up the person's iron,
you could get what's called anemia of chronic disease.
And that's a person who, you know, you could say,
well, I don't want to take iron,
because iron can feed the cancer.
Well, you're kind of in a catch 22 situation.
I have anemia.
I'm exhausted all the time because of my anemia,
because it's the iron that's needed
for the hemoglobin to carry oxygen to the tissues.
So you're going to have fatigue
and continue to ramp up fatigue with anemia.
So you're in that catch 22.
I need to take iron.
What am I supposed to do?
Well, this is where we like to couple iron
with arnamycinin or the laetrol, the B17,
because iron, these two things tend to follow iron.
So if we're going to give iron to the body
because we need to deal with this person's anemia,
we also have to know that we might be feeding the cancer
a little bit by doing this also.
Okay, well, what am I going to do?
I have to get rid of my fatigue.
My red blood cell count is too low.
My doctor wants me to take iron.
Well, we, number one, we do not want to take
a poor source of iron.
And by that, I mean the ferrous sulfate,
which would be typically something
that's going to be subscribed to you or prescribed to you,
or typically something that you'll get over the counter
at Walbarr or something is the ferrous sulfate.
Really horrible source of iron.
Very hard to digest.
Very hard on the gut.
Constipates people most of the time.
You want to take either a plant-based iron.
We've been recommending the ferro-food
as a plant-based iron.
The problem is, is that the straight plant-based irons
tend to not boost up the iron levels fast enough.
That's what we've been seeing lately.
So that we are switching to the ferrous shell,
which is a ferrous bish glistening,
which is the double bond glycine on the ferrous compound
as you'd get in a plant, but it's that higher milligram dose.
So if we have to give iron to help with the anemia,
we want to give either artimisticid,
which is the artimistia adiwa,
or the laetro, the B-17, to go along with it.
So we take it at the same time or near the same time
within the hour or so after you take the iron,
so that it will go along with the iron into the cancer cell.
If the cancer cell is going to uptake it.
So if the cancer cell is going to uptake the iron,
we want artimisticid or the laetro to go with it.
And you can alternate between the two of these.
As a test, you can take artimisticid one day,
be 17 the next day.
That's a good way to do it if you think of that.
So you're taking the artimisticid and the B-17
that it's going to tie onto the iron in your system.
It's going to be dragged into the cancer cell.
That's the goal.
And it's going to help kill the cancer cell.
So if we're going to bring the iron into the cancer cell,
we're going to bring something that's going to kill it
at the same time.
And this will hurt your normal cell, so this is fine to take.
So that's just our theory about that to try to.
If we have to feed the rest of the body iron,
if we're going to be feeding the cancer,
let's kill it at the same time.
That's our plan with that.
OK, so let's open it up for questions.
I'm going to unmute everybody.
And we've got a few minutes for questions.
Anything?
Dr. Connors.
Hi, how are you?
Hello, young lady.
So the artimisman and the B-17, they're
not going to take the iron that you need.
No.
No, no, no.
OK.
So they don't suck onto the iron
like they're going to gobble an operating thing like that.
No, no, no.
They just happen to be nutrients that follow iron.
So the theory is, OK, if we have to give iron,
well, let's give these two.
So maybe these will help kill the cancer, so.
OK.
Thank you.
Well, we have got an idea of a question.
Yes, I do.
I'd like to go back to the kidney stone issue.
I just got my blood work done on the second of July.
And I got the results back.
And my calcium level went from 12.0 to 12.8.
My question is, I read all labels,
and I make sure that I do not have
any additional calcium in any of my supplements or anything else.
Could it be, well, I have multiple myeloma,
so I know that a lot of it calcium comes out of my bones.
But could it be something that I might be eating?
Also.
No.
So historically, your dietary sources of calcium,
if even if you were taking a whole bunch of calcium supplements,
it's not going to raise your blood calcium.
So it's not going to raise your blood calcium levels.
You're going to, OK, can you hear me still?
Typically, only thing that's going to raise your blood calcium
levels is either a parathyroid problem.
And parathyroid tumors are not uncommon at all,
or bolus of some sort.
So calcium consumption is like calcium tablets,
or I'm drinking a whole bunch of milk,
or which is not a good source of calcium.
People's thoughts with that, it's not due to that.
So whatever a person's calcium, blood calcium levels
are higher, you think, bonus somewhere
or parathyroid issues.
OK.
Well, yeah, I know that a lot of the calcium problem
is from the multiple myeloma, but I have a praise.
The multiple myeloma went from 2.6 to 2.2,
within a very short period of time.
So that was kind of confusing, because my myeloma's
going down, which is good, but then the calcium's jumped pretty high.
Yeah, so are you doing that every two weeks,
that calcium level test?
No, no, I had it done.
I had it done in the end of April.
So I do it about every three months.
Well, I would bump that up to at least once a month.
See if you could just get that calcium level checked
on a more regular basis by your doctor.
They should do that.
Yeah, yeah, there's no problem.
I can have it done at any time.
OK, good.
Thank you.
Any other questions?
Yes, sir.
I have a question.
Yeah, I went to your office on July, I think,
4th and 7th, but yeah.
And I wonder about my picture.
You have a chance to look?
Yes, I did.
I think I think one of the girls emailed you back
about that question you had.
Yeah.
Yeah, there wasn't it.
We're not making any changes in your protocol due to that.
But we will be when we get your genetics back,
which we haven't gotten back yet.
So we're still waiting though that the lab is to come back on that.
Takes a few weeks, you spend on how busy they are.
We're running about three, four weeks or so
on the genetics right now.
So we'll let you know the girls.
I don't think you where they don't notify the patient,
but we'll be notified as soon as they get back.
Yeah, and also the picture that meets your take.
Oh, yeah, she'll get back to you.
I think Michelle, I think Ashley was
going to reach out to you today or tomorrow on that.
So she's going to do a Zoom call with you with that.
So she'll go over with the computer.
Similar to this call right here, you'll
be able to see the biography on your computer.
So you want to be out of computer when you do that?
And how about a one that they take from a phone,
take that one picture from a cell phone?
OK, yes.
Dr. Connors, this is Michelle on the line.
Yeah, I can speak to that.
Dr. Connors and I have had a chance to discuss that yet.
It's been pretty crazy in the office the last few days.
And so we've been trying to make it
through everything from the holiday weekend.
So I had been planning on speaking to him about it this week,
but we have not gotten to that yet.
I will get back to you on that as soon as he
and I have a chance to connect.
Oh, OK, I kind of wonder.
You be practical either teething or teething or teething.
Given what I had seen from the photo,
I would not probably be thinking
that any additional treatment is necessary.
Everything that you are doing right now is great
and is meant to continue going forward.
So I don't believe we'd be changing anything.
So don't fret about that.
Everything you're doing right now
is just fine.
I thought you were talking about the thermography.
Yeah, no, that was my mistake.
So we'll talk about them this week.
OK.
But I think Ashley was going to get back
to you tomorrow about your thermography.
So she hasn't done that already.
Oh, don't want coffee.
I know you're not taking it at your office.
Oh, you did it.
OK.
Yeah, I just have a flywalk pass.
Yeah.
And the picture that we talked about.
And I wonder why I kind of feel numb on my leg.
It barely to walk, especially the light side, but feel numb.
They feel numb like you can't.
Like if you push on it, you can't feel anything.
Sometimes we can feel, but sometimes we cannot.
Because I did not walk for a while.
Maybe a week already.
Right.
So when you came in here, you weren't walking.
And so are you ambulatory yet?
Are you able to get up and move around yet?
I can move my arm freely.
No problem.
But that's my kind of problem because maybe we
could not walk for a while.
It can be inflammation on those lumbar nerves.
That it's your left side, you said?
Yeah, on the left side.
OK.
So it can be inflammation on those lumbar nerves.
If it's only on one side in your lower extremities,
that's what I would think it's more of a peripheral nerve
problem.
If it was both sides that I'd be more
concerned with like a spinal fracture,
a compression fracture, so it's better
than it's only on one side.
Do you have a lot of inflammation in your tummy?
In my tummy, I just feel numb sometimes.
OK.
Do you have a lot of swelling or anything in your tummy?
No, no.
No.
No fluid or fluid build up or anything like that?
No, basically it's a juda.
It's a juda anima.
So if that numbness doesn't start to go away,
you may want to get some x-rays of your lumbar spine
just to make sure.
Oh.
And how they can fix the problem, sir.
Yeah, that's if number one, if it's because of any compression
fracture, that's going to just take some time to heal.
Oh.
So if it's because of just irritation to the nerves,
that's, it takes time for those to heal.
Are you doing the, are you able to do the foot bath at all?
Yeah, I did.
Why are you already?
OK, so keep doing those.
I think that will help a lot, too.
So try to do those maybe even every other day or so.
I think that will be a help, too.
Oh, OK.
So you can slowly get up and start moving.
I think that will help as well get some motion in there,
be very careful with weight buried.
But motion in there will help as well.
And how about a acupuncture, sir?
Acupuncture would be great.
Oh.
Yes, acupuncture would be a great treatment for that.
So that will really help that whole area heal.
What do you mean on the back and leg?
Yes, yeah, absolutely.
Or anything else that you may be at right?
Well, the other thing that might help
is using the attend's unit.
Are you familiar with the attend's unit?
No, sir.
So attend's unit, we have them here at the office.
They're very inexpensive little electric steam units
that just run off batteries.
They're a little teeny like the size of a cell phone.
And they're meant to put on areas of pain, numbness,
tingling, muscle issues.
That can really help stimulate adornful and kephaline
production that can help heal.
Wow.
They're like 50 bucks for attend's unit.
So it's really worth it.
They were created a number of years ago
for people with compression fractures
because of cancer or disk issues that are not going to go away.
They're meant to be used 24, 7 if you need to.
That's why they're made really small.
So you can just stick them in your pocket
and keep it on all the time.
We've had a number of people that have used those
with really good success to calm things down
and to decrease symptoms.
That's something we can look into too.
If you want to call the office in the morning,
we can send one out to you.
OK.
Again, the name, what's the name, sir?
Tens, T-E-N-S, like the number 10.
Oh, oh.
But it has a transcutaneous electrical nerve
stimulation as what it stands for.
Oh, and also I wonder about the Ryma chain.
I used, like I kind of recycle,
like I used at night and then they calm.
I used again, that'd be OK or not.
What is it?
I mean, the Ryma chain.
I used at night, at night, at night, at night, at night,
I used, yeah, I'm not sure what it is that you're speaking of.
If you want to have, if you want to or your husband wants
to email what that is, then we can email back what I'm not
sure what product that is or what prescription that is.
I get from your outfit, they're called too light.
I think she's saying rice machine.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yeah, so you're using that every night, right?
Yes, and also I wonder, the ISH program
I can repeat again in that time.
Absolutely.
So you can repeat that same program during the daytime, yes.
Oh, how about the nerve repair, whatever.
That one I can repeat too, right?
Yes, you can repeat any of those programs.
You can do it too much.
So use it over and over again, absolutely.
Oh, so you're not going to be inside, like I dehydrated anything?
Oh, no, no.
Use it as much as you want.
Oh, OK.
So the frequency is going to be the same thing, right?
Yes, so you can run it during the day at night.
You can run that whole program again.
Or if you want to run any of this shorter programs,
you can certainly run those during the day as well.
OK.
Nana.
Yeah, also, I have a question about food.
I hear about the back sond.
It's kind of good for cleaning.
What is your opinion, sir?
I didn't fully understand that question.
What was the thing that you were talking about?
The black sond for my party's at Hanoi, I don't know.
The black sond.
Black.
Sond.
Yeah.
They said, if doing with water, it kind of helps cleaning inside.
But I'm not sure about it going to harm the kidney or anything or not.
It's kind of salty.
Back sond power.
Is it black salt?
Yeah.
Back sond power.
S-A-L-T.
Yes, sir.
So is it like from the Hawaiian black salt?
No, from Pakistan Hanoi India.
India?
Yeah.
I mean, it still will break down the sodium chloride.
The benefit, it has the black salt, is typically volcanic origin.
So it has that, has some binding qualities for chemicals in the gut.
So yeah, within reason, there's no problem with that.
If a person has high blood pressure issues or a lot of swelling in their legs, then they
have to be careful with how much sodium is in there.
But if that's not an issue, you could take it, either use it out of your food or take
it.
I know people that have teaspoon of that in water or something like that, yes, you could
use some of that.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Thank you, Dr.
Yes.
Yeah.
So maybe someone had a question.
Yes.
Any other questions from anybody?
Okay.
Well, we'll get this recording up on Facebook.
Feel free to ask questions on Facebook and feel free to email us questions, remember?
But please, in the subject line, put Zoom call question.
Because again, we get hundreds of emails on a daily basis, and they could easily get lost.
I don't want you to think that we're ignoring you.
So thank you guys, have a great day, and we will talk again next week.
Oh, that's one more question.
Uh-huh.
Yeah.
I'm going to take the, also, then, also, then we'll see injection.
So, okay, how often should I do that?
So what injection is it?
Or therapy.
Uh-uh.
Ozone therapy.
Where are you going to get those?
Where are you going to get that injected?
Is that through the bloodstream you're getting?
Ozone?
Yeah.
She take the blood out, and then we take the blood out.
So, doing that on a typically, doing that on a weekly basis?
Okay.
Makes sense.
Yeah.
Uh-uh.
We'll see.
We'll see, too.
Yeah.
You can do that weekly.
You can do that more often than that, but I'd start out weekly before you go into doing it
twice a week, just to make sure you're tolerated it.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Thank you, sir.
Okay.
All right.
Everybody.
We will see you next week.
Thank you.